of all his games miyazaki said that
bloodborne has stayed in his heart the
most
i believe i did it my way the way i
wanted it it is
what most struck me i feel like this
statement will resonate with a lot of
people
because people love bloodborne in fact
i'd say it's actually in the running for
the most beloved ip from has created
even up against dark souls which
spans three games and reached a much
wider multi-platform audience
basically bloodborne has a cult
following within a community that is
already
a cult following despite this
fromsoftware and sony have yet to
announce a sequel
when asked about bloodborne 2 miyazaki
said that the decision isn't his to make
it's sony's which is something he also
said about demon souls right before the
remake
mind you so it's possible likely even
that we will eventually see bloodborne 2
on the ps5
but what would a sequel even look like
would we return to the dim streets of
yharnam or somewhere else entirely
what comes next in the ending with the
waking world or
what does it truly mean to ascend what
new trick weapons would we wield which
nightmare realms would we explore
and do hints at bloodborne 2
already exist in their other games
artists
we beg you as you once did in previous
art competitions
grant us eyes grant us eyes plant
eyes on our brains to cleanse our
beastly idiocy this arts competition
is called imagining bloodborne 2 and
it's the fifth and final art competition
on the channel
for the foreseeable future at least
artists will be competing for their
slice
of 2 500 split between the top 10
winners
who along with some runners-up will also
receive
a favorable shout out on the channel in
this competition
you can draw anything as long as it
relates to the theme of bloodborne
2 so whether your strength is in
environments
weapons bosses enemies npcs it's all on
the table
if you're interested in competing you
can learn the explicit rules and
guidelines at the end of this video but
until then for the sake of everyone's
insight i want to discuss
the themes the allure and the law of
bloodborne
a good place to start in understanding
the story of bloodborne
are the couple of overview videos i've
done on it alternatively you could also
go and read the pale blood hunt
a comprehensive essay by dmc redgrave by
furthering your understanding of what we
do know about bloodborne
you'll naturally get an idea of what we
don't know
which could be important if you're
trying to imagine bloodborne 2
for example the game could be a prequel
set in the age of the two marians
or maybe it could be a sequel taking
place after one of the endings
or maybe you have the knowledge to
imagine something else maybe a sort of
parallel story that
occurs somewhere else entirely of course
thinking on a smaller scale is just as
valid for the art competitions
maybe you just want to build out a
faction like the vilebloods
or the powder keg hunters maybe an item
description hints at an
area outside the game or maybe one of
the stories in the game just helps to
inspire the weapon that you're designing
my point is knowing the law will go a
long way in
inspiring you for a sequel and it's best
to incorporate
law somehow when we started playing
bloodborne in 2015
we thought we had a grip on what it was
just a stereotypical victorian era
horror story right
infected townsfolk trenchcoats
werewolves
night of the hunt got it you think you
know what you're getting into
until you don't sooner or later
something should feel
off maybe it was when you found the
aliens tucked away in the woods
or perhaps it was when you gave that
password at the door only to find that
you were talking to an inanimate corpse
on the other side there was that moment
when you were lifted into the sky and
crushed by an invisible force
and god forbid you have enough insight
to figure out what you were just crushed
by
at the core of bloodborne isn't really
the werewolves it's not the gothic
architecture
it's the fear of the unknown it's the
idea that mankind are swept up by the
tides
created by greater beings and that the
truth is so vast and terrifying that it
would destroy you
if only you could understand it the
developers even built this concept of
terrible truth into the gameplay with a
mechanic called
insight insight is a resource that you
gain when you witness
certain things things like seeing the
cleric beast for the first time
or witnessing the aliens tucked away in
the forest
insight can be used to purchase powerful
items but having too much can actually
be a burden
some enemies gain new attacks your
frenzy resistance is reduced
and you might also start to see and hear
unsettling things so the developers were
definitely trying to create something
with the inside mechanic that
represents both the human desire to seek
knowledge
and also the inability of the human mind
to comprehend
terrible truths that's cosmic horror and
that's
lovecraft h.p lovecraft pioneered this
sort of horror
back in the early 20th century and if
you want to better understand bloodborne
then you should definitely go and read
some of his stories for example the
shadow over innsmouth
largely inspired the fishing hamlet
mountains over madness has great
analogues to the chalice dungeons
and the dream quest of unknown kadath
references
many worlds of dream and nightmare if
you're looking to enter the art
competition
i have no doubt that you will find a ton
of inspiration
in the lovecraft mythos especially if
you go and read some of the stories that
i didn't
just mention now while i consider
lovecraft to be largely inseparable from
bloodborne
i feel like the victorian era gothic
vibe isn't
i think it'd be kind of fascinating to
see bloodborne 2 take place
in a different cultural background i've
kind of speculated on this before
in a video i made back when the shadows
die twice
teaser wasn't confirmed to be for sakura
and
it got me thinking then about a sort of
japanese lovecraftian horror
and personally i'd love to see the
influence of the great ones spread to
different historical settings
but what do you think it's also possible
that the aesthetic of bloodborne is
very rooted in the victorian era the
question is
do we think that this gothic setting
could be meaningfully expanded in a
sequel
or would we prefer to go somewhere else
entirely
i think both options are valid there
were even rumors
a while back that an aztec setting could
be a future place for from software to
explore
coincidentally this was around the same
time desracine was released
which is a psvr game made by
fromsoftware that
naturally very few people had the
hardware to play
it was a good game but ultimately most
people heard about dyrasine
because it contained a few references to
bloodborne most notable
being this small doll and perhaps this
book
titled blood and bones along with an
intriguing description that you should
pause and read
on screen the cover features a lightly
dressed warrior
equipped with what looked like claws in
his left hand
with a bird returning to his shoulder in
order to render this in more detail i
commissioned
sebastian francini who is an incredibly
talented illustrator whose work has
actually
kind of become the face of the channel
in recent months
please go and follow their socials down
below they're an amazing artist
this is our take on the character on the
book cover
but it's not the only way you could
interpret it this
moon could actually be a sun or an
eclipse perhaps these are crows or
ravens
or eagles perhaps it's this
meso-american themed
desert aztec warrior or perhaps it's
just a classic hunter
what do you think many people including
me speculated that these references
in de rasoni could actually be a nod
towards bloodborne 2
and enough people were saying this to
the point where
from software actually commented which
is pretty rare for them
uh saying that they just put these
things in de racine
as easter eggs and that they did not
intend to cause
great inconvenience to sony by spreading
these rumors
i hardly feel like hype for a bloodborne
sequel is a great inconvenience to sony
it's probably a good thing from their
perspective if anything but i do
kind of feel bad for helping to spread
those rumors
so i will say this the last thing i want
to do is put
pressure on from software or sony to
create something that they don't want to
make
hell myself and many others i know
actually think that
bloodborne stands very well on its own
and doesn't even need a sequel
at all but that said speculation is fun
art is good
discussion about bloodborne is healthy
and these competitions exist in their
own little world
and it should be considered separate
from any official endorsement by from
software
and sony but i really can't imagine that
sony aren't
courting from software in some way they
must be a really enviable developer to
work with
sony was really pleased with the success
of bloodborne
from software's secure went on to win a
major game of the year award
and now sony has the playstation 5 which
will eventually need
hardcore fans to drive hardware sales
so i would love to see what a next-gen
bloodborne could look and play like
especially because
console players are finally going to
understand how painful
30 frames per second has been this past
generation
and that kind of brings me to gameplay
bloodborne's gameplay is defined by a
few things
first there's the health regain mechanic
where you can recoup some health by
striking back at an enemy after they've
hit you
second there are trick weapons that
transform with a button press to present
this wider array of attacks
third bloodborne's combat really
revolves around dodging which contrasts
with the blocking focus of dark souls
or the parrying focus of secure fourth
blood vials heal you quickly
and can be farmed out in the world fifth
the map design
loops back on itself quite often with
many opportunities for shortcuts
and lastly insight which we mentioned
earlier
but there's more of course and i
mentioned these things because if you
were to imagine bloodborne 2
how would you innovate on this gameplay
would you innovate
on this gameplay personally for example
i'd like to see more
fast paced hunter style boss fights and
less
giant monster boss fights since i think
bloodborne's really fast style combat
really shines in 1v1 combat with chip
damage
second i'd probably innovate on the
dodge mechanic i'd probably give some
sort of
bonus if you dodge a melee attack
perfectly similar to
how if you parry perfectly in secure you
knock them off balance
and third i'd like to see more weapons
especially
ranged weapons and arcane spells which i
think is really limited
in the original game if you have any
criticisms or thoughts like these then
work them into your entry you know make
your feelings known
through your art and i think most
entries should mention gameplay in some
way
not all of them but it probably can't
hurt to mention something about the
gameplay right
so for example if you're designing a
trick weapon you should
make the weapon move sets and
transformations and
you know range and maybe even damage
very clear bosses might have paragraphs
about their different
phases and move sets or maybe you want
to talk about how your npc that you drew
might react when they get aggroed you
know that sort of thing
even environments might have a line or
two devoted to gameplay whether there's
environmental effects
like poison or freezing or how the
player traverses the environment or
what they experience within the
environment this is all most likely
worth a mention
it helps to ground the player in the
world and
we are imagining a video game after all
i actually also made a community post
asking what people would like to see
from bloodborne 2 and
it received over three and a half
thousand replies
so if you're having trouble getting
inspiration for your art competition
go and comb through that post and also
the comments in this video
you know maybe you'll realize that
bloodborne 2 should be
a bergenworth high school dating
simulator with microtransactions
who knows i'd also recommend looking
back at the previous
four art competitions for a better idea
of what criteria are important to the
judges
so you can turn your concepts whatever
it is
into a frontrunner i can't wait to see
what our artists can come up with
i seriously feel like we have some of
the most talented artists in the
industry in our community
and i hope that everything i just talked
about serves as a good foundation
for your inspiration so now let's talk
about more explicit rules and
guidelines for your submission the due
date for your submission is around two
months from now
april 1st 11 pm pst there's a tiny bit
of leeway on this
so don't stress out if you're a day or
two late
make sure you convert your image or
images into an attachable
jpeg or png and submit it to
bloodborne2challenge
gmail.com try to render your image in a
size that can be
attached to an email but if it's too big
please upload it to a cloud service and
link me to it and make sure that you
have your permissions
set correctly so that i can view it in
the body of your email please
include the name you'd like to go by
your paypal address
and a link to your artist's portfolio or
social media
if you have them if your submission has
law
gameplay or any written description
really
then you can either write this in the
body of your email
or you can make it a part of your
artwork or you can attach
a document with that information if you
have additional questions
just join the discord link in the
description and check out
the faq channel and our art chat where
moderators can answer your questions in
real time
i'd also like to give a bit of a
disclaimer like i did in the last video
that by entering this art competition
you're giving me permission to
potentially include your art in this art
book that
i'd really like to make i want to
immortalize these entries in a better
format than video and i want the art
book to feature people who
weren't just in the top ten i want to
open it up to a lot more people and
give them a bit of credit as well so if
you're chosen to be in the art book i
will of course contact you
and we can figure out how to best
represent you and your art in the book
and so far i am committed to getting
every artist who has included a free
copy of the book at least
if it is ever made and i'm also working
on some other methods of funding your
reimbursement as well but i can't
confirm that this will happen at the
moment but i am trying
so thank you for your contributions to
this community art competitions bring
myself and everyone who watches them so
much joy so
thank you i can't wait to see what you
create seriously and
i'll talk to you then
you